tes mains résolvent les problèmes je sors les
poubelles j'enlève les taches difficiles à atteindre les
autres mettent juste comme ça
mon partenaire a été coupé tu m'as donné ta
parole que tu sors de cette affaire
c'est le dernier obstacle
je ne referai plus jamais ça
tu es une sorte de partenaire qu'est-ce que tu
vas faire faire sortir du kungfu de la
patrie je suis né en Floride
je voudrais que tu élimines l'ennemi que
tu traites en toute sécurité avec un
ex-mercenaire il va poinçonner ton
billet et je vais te regarder  ne te contente pas de
tuer un gars comme ça je viens de le faire
hé j'ai quelque chose que tu veux papa
bien verbeux quand j'arrive à Scottie
ça te dérange si nous écoutons quelque chose de
ce siècle je ne peux pas te laisser partir le cerveau de Kelly
désolé sonne comme un cassé  enregistrer
qu'ils ne le font même pas  fais plus de disques
toi et moi bas des affaires inachevées
- ouais tu vas te battre tu prévois de l'
ennuyer juste
je sais que j'ai entendu le discours dans lequel nous aurions
dû l'emmener ne fais confiance à personne
c'est comme ça que tu restes dans le jeu
abattre Oh